[Musique]
diane bérard nicolas duvernois au ca ce
soir nos chers membres bonsoir bonsoir
concert 22 éléments et à être au groupe
américain sur dix nord nicolas qu'est ce
que vous en pensez de cette transaction
et kt et moi j'ai arrêté de respirer
quand j'ai appris cette vente la mine
c'est un fiasco du début à la fin je ne
comprends pas ce qui s'est passé avec ça
c'est notre obsession la de vouloir
bâtir des multinationales délits comme
délicate et on veut que toutes les
entreprises le valin milliards
finalement on est tombé dans un monde de
licorne où ça valait absolument rien
j'ai pas compris du début jusqu'à la fin
le modèle d'affaires de stands mais
pourquoi c'est un fiasco
qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est un
fiasco et saint-pierre secours parce que
là on est en train de perdre
combien de centaines d'ingénieurs
québécois qui vont maintenant travailler
pour une entreprise américaine qui elle
a les poches assez profondes ou plus ou
moins si ce qu'elle va faire avec cette
entreprise j'imagine s'est relâché et
puis ils vont développer de la richesse
pour une entreprise qui vient d'ailleurs
dit c'est ça qui est en face au puy le
fiasco 6,6 et surtout désolé mais
d'avoir fait de cette entreprise là la
plus belle révolution depuis pas être
tranchée qu'en absolument personne
savait ce qu'elle faisait
dionne moi je vais utiliser deux
citations
alors les gens de services non la
licorne qui ont acheté et les matériels
à l'icône rappel c'est une entreprise
qui est valorisé à plus de 1 million de
dollars américains en bourse
donc je cite services non a dit
clairement qu'elle compte renforcer sa
position dominante en tirant parti des
brillants esprits d'élémentaire alors ça
se passe de commentaire on a des
brillants esprits que vont servir à
propulser une licorne américaine
et deuxième chose yoshua bengio qui est
conseil comme une sommité mondiale de
l'intelligence artificielle agir à titre
de conseiller technique pour re services
a encore une fois il faut se désole
qu'une que des brillants esprits
québécois vont servir à propulser glycol
américaine oui ces croyants il faut s'en
désoler
même temps j'ai entendu aujourd'hui
monsieur fils given puis monsieur aimons
aussi de la caisse de dépôt qui disait
mais ce modèle d'affaires là la
rentabilité de l'application
d'élémentaire pour amener des
entreprises à utiliser
l'intelligence artificielle on n'a pas
réussi à la rentabiliser donc fallait
trouver une solution quand même nicolas
non moi je crois que le problème était
même avant rentabiliser une idée ou un
modèle d'affaires c'est une chose savoir
c'est quoi le modèle d'affaires c'en est
une autre
je comprends le gouvernement et je suis
très d'accord avec le gouvernement de ne
pas racheter cette entreprise là on ne
peut pas avoir essayé de trouver cette
entreprise doit pas ce que veut racheter
les pots cassés d'une entreprise dans
laquelle je le rappelle il on le vit 348
millions de dollars ou une entreprise
qu'on ne savait pas encore une fois je
le répète le sait juste juste le monde
réalise que témoin je regarde après à
côté il ya plein de jeunes pousses là
une superbe et d'entreprises dans
l'intelligence artificielle à montréal
qui reçoivent des pinottes et qui font
réellement des grandes avancées et des
développements il a tout d'un coup il ya
une entreprise qui arrive comme un don
de dieu pour le québec et finalement
choisi rien est ce que c'est une
critique diane du travail de jean
françois garnier le pdg le yoshua bengio
également le cofondateur je reviendrai
sur ce que nicolas a dit effectivement
il y avait quelque chose d'opaque dans
élémentaire on était très fier d'avoir
une entreprise en intelligence
artificielle
il y avait quelque chose de pas qu'il ya
aussi le fait qu'un enjeu à valoriser la
recherche comment on fait pour valoriser
la recherche trouver un modèle
d'affaires à partir de du fruit de la
recherche cauchois bendjo c'est d'abord
un chercheur donc est ce que c'est un yo
l'obsession de la licorne donc à quelque
part on voit le sauveur venu des états
unis est compliqué dionne la licorne
c'est quoi mais la licom comme jeu c'est
une entreprise qui est valorisé à 1
million de dollars et plus d'un million
qu'ils aient un milliard il ya un
millier un milieu
le dollar américain est plus et ont une
obsession de créer des licornes la
bourse
ml comme la bourse veut délits comme
edward et des licornes bain les à
verchères vad est l'icône des
gouvernements se disent les licornes
vont devenir grosse vont payer des taxes
vont employer des gens mais à quelques
morts est ce que c'est que le modèle
qu'on souhaite pour la société la lmp1
est avalée par nikon et on dit elle est
sauvée il faut sauver les emplois
nicolas et à faire des licornes c'est
bien fatigué banni en parle beaucoup
piano mais toutes sortes d'entreprises
aujourd'hui parler de lightspeed pi2
brainbox c'est quand même intéressant de
développer cet écosystème la mort mais
absolument et ces entreprises ont prouvé
qu'ils quittaient qu'ils avaient des
clients ils avaient des revenus qu'ils
avaient litespeed s'adonnent à des
centaines de millions de revenus il ya
un modèle dash-l en arrière il ya de la
réalité lacan humanise on l'a
démocratisons ce qui s'est passé avec
elle-même t elle c'est quoi c'est une
entreprise qui a promis terre et mandat
des personnes qui ont cru en elle
ils ont construit des bureaux somptueuse
ont engagé des centaines de personnes
ils ont fait le tour de la planète à
recevoir des prix des médailles des prix
étudiés déplier tic-tac
et puis j'avais plus ou moins un gourou
à la tête savait comment s'appelle
s'appelle une secte mais je n'ai pas
besoin de vous les loups et niko non
parce que dans le monde des affaires
depuis trois ans tout le monde se pose
la question et il faut quoi moi je me
sens un chasse à venir holtz à manger
des croquettes sa voix dans une vie
tiers aux toilettes et c'est facile
comme réponse quand moi je développe des
produits moins chers de l'alcool je suis
ultra celle ci il semble que défauts
qu'on n'arrive pas à donner à répondre
mais facile bien sûr le modèle
d'affaires il ya déjà un problème mais
je pense qu'il faut faire la différence
entre une icône qui fabrique un produit
qui est nécessaire à la société on ne
cite l asp de lightspeed fait des
solutions de paiement pour les petits
détaillants litespeed permet la vitalité
des quartiers grâce au petit détaillant
l'eau dans un autre modèle on parle
d'intelligence artificielle on parle de
service donc c'est pas le modèle de la
licorne qu'il faut questionner sait à
quoi sert la licorne et comme elles
contribuent à l'économie de quelle façon
donc cette obsession d'alico on devrait
la laisser tomber ses 10 ans
des entreprises qui grossissent dans
quel secteur pour rendre quel service à
la société
ok alors parfait on s'arrête là pour
l'instant sur ce sujet là le mot chacun
sur le resserrement de l'encadrement du
magasin du magasinage des fêtes avec des
policiers un petit peu partout dans les
magasins des menaces demande
vous en pensez-quoi dionne moi je pense
que c'est grand il est grand temps de
revoir notre stratégie de noix de
magasinage de noël comme consommateur ce
qu'est ce que samedi c'est deux choses
d'abord on pratique la la on magasine
seul on magasine selon la technique
commando on rend ton pays on sort mais
idéalement ce serait déjà ça moi mais
idéal mal an on va pas dans les magasins
on commet dans l'est et j'aimerais en
profiter pour une suggestion à tout le
québec
je pense qu'il faudrait déplacer nos
actions et notre budget des fêtes vers
les secteurs qui en ont besoin et je
lance un défi à tous les québécois
d'acheter dans les cadeaux de leurs
proches
un repas au restaurant à emporter pour
aider les restaurateurs et ensuite de
sauver tout même chose pour la musique
est tellement un bon jardinier gothel
mêmes choses qu'on est là sur deux
bouteilles de vin on est obligé
d'acheter tout notre vin à la saq on
peut en acheter une ou deux bouteilles
chez les restaurateurs parce qu'ils ont
droit devancé avec les rares absolument
non que la belle chez le très sage
décision actée cc c'est c'est pour
protéger la santé autant d employer que
des clients
franchement bravo parfait je vous pose
pas la question tout de suite on va
laisser le temps passer d'ici le 11
décembre à savoir qu'est-ce que qu'est
ce que le gouvernement devrait faire
avec les rassemblements mais on sent
qu'il ya une épée de damoclès au dessus
de nos têtes là dessus nicolas je veux
finir avec vous c'est le jour de la
grande guignolée domaine
la guignolée des médias et vous attendez
20 porte parole de l'événement qui prend
quand même une forme un peu particulière
cette année mais on s'entend que la
pandémie m'a fait que augmenter les
besoins en denrées alimentaires dons
d'argent m
en dons de produits origines
personnelles donc c'est clair qu'on m'a
approché pour devenir l'un des
porte-parole des médias j'étais
extrêmement honoré vous savez la
pauvreté maroc ne fait aucune
discrimination quand je joue au basket
bat la jeunesse au soleil quand j'étais
plus jeune je voyais les lignes de
personnes qui attendaient pour le compte
en alimentaire je venais pas quel point
ces des personnes qui me ressemblait et
donc c'est super important de doni je
vous en supplie voilà et vous avez donc
que vous pouvez texter ou données en
ligne parce que là on avait des images
de gens dans la rue ça n'arrivera pas
demain
alors faut faire ça en ligne soyez
généreux merci à vous deux bonsoir et
merci